those who are branded with the dark sign
will live forever but is eternal life a
blessing or a curse the theocracy in the
land is based around the way of white
which follows the will of Lord Gwyn
serving under Gwyn our esteemed houses
like the house of thorolund think for a
moment about what you know of churches
that existed in medieval times churches
seek control of all people in the name
of God and are conservative by nature
they fear change one day people become
branded with eternal life this would
disrupt the balance and naturally the
church would fear this but how to deal
with it should you label it as a
blessing and as the will of God no if
this eternal life ended with people
losing the will to live and becoming
Hollow then why not label the dark sign
as a curse we don't know what made the
dark sign but the church made it evil so
what happens if a member of the church
becomes Undead
to keep the age of fire going bonfires
can be fed humanity through the art of
kindling hidden deep within the
catacombs is room and to be a technique
where bonfires can be fed to grow even
stronger the way of white seeks this
knowledge to better serve Lord Gwyn the
first undead member of the church was a
paladin in golden armor equipped with
legendary treasures he set out on the
first undead mission of the way of white
a mission for the rite of kindling from
this point forth all undead within the
church are sent on this same mission
this serves two purposes firstly if any
undead succeeds in retrieving the right
then the church will grow more powerful
secondly it doesn't matter if the
mission ends in failure because the
church will have rid themselves of
accursed undead Rhea is a daughter of
the house of thorolund which is
inarguably the most prestigious
religious family however she becomes
undead and even her high birth cannot
save her from undergoing the undead
mission so Rhea is shipped to Lord Ron
with two companions in a futile search
for kindling upon arrival Rhea meets
Petrus Petrus is an undead cleric who
resides at Firelink shrine he guides
undead on their mission but there's more
to this man in there seems your first
clue comes from the items he has stashed
under filing shrine your second clue
comes from the partner has Quinn's
Petrus
I u2 has likely far much income for is
he not to drench in sin shortly after
they arrived Rhea and her party
disappeared deep into the catacombs
for a while the player will notice their
absence from the game eventually however
Petrus will return and he returns alone
oh you again me
I've become separated from the lady I've
scoured near and far but no sight of her
where could she have gone milady
do you think I swore to protect you with
my life he's lying Petrus will gladly
admit to his crimes if you discover the
truth through law Trek Petrus reveals
that he hates the lady for her high
birth but why did he abandon her perhaps
he doesn't think she's worth it perhaps
he is a coward or perhaps it is his job
to ensure that undead never returned
from the catacombs
good day you look reasonably sane what
are you doing in the catacombs are you a
cleric or something Maidan Thurl and and
her followers recently arrived in this
land but she became stranded deep below
the catacombs her followers either fled
or were reduced to hollows leaving
Maidan feral and all alone not a bad
tipper a new bar cleric would be replete
with humanity law trek suggests that you
robbed the helpless girl of her humanity
she is alone in a dark pit surrounded by
her hollow friends and no way of escape
are you thank goodness
please be careful there are two-faced
hollows not far from here they were once
brave knights
my former escorts who would let such
strong spirits be hollows oh heavens is
there nothing nothing at all to be done
have you spoken with Sir Lautrec
splendid in the depths of the catacombs
milady slipped off the Giants coffin and
into a hole her two companions are no
longer human and the lass
weeps in solitude right now you could do
as you please with her the poor little
purebred is entirely helpless
did you think of the trouble my feelings
of cost I am certain that both Vince and
Nico are grateful to you oh it's you you
rescued milady
well a pity that is for it will amount
to nothing for the little madam is not
worth her salt without her family name
after everything you find RIA alone
praying in the church David's dead Niko
forgive me I have lost all those who are
close to me perhaps Petrus realized my
weakness all along and thus made the
decision to abandon me I can hardly
blame him now if I do go all oh and
finish me off
I beg you this is where the path splits
that both paths end in death if you do
not kill Petrus for abandoning real then
RIA will die Petrus plays innocent but
if you kill him after her death you will
find her ivory talisman upon his person
perhaps Petrus kills Rhea to keep her
quiet
perhaps he hates her high birth or
perhaps disposing of undead is his job
but if you kill Petrus for abandoning
real then she will not be assassinated
fine by the Lord's you can fool enough
of you feel the wrath of the gods fool
what were you thinking too bad for you
I'm a wolf in sheep's clothing driven to
madness by emotion so be it you'll make
a fine hollow you can waltz in the
infernal depths together no this can't
be it can't end like this if an undead
has a purpose then they will not Hollow
Rhea will teach you Erica's in the
church until she has nothing left to
teach you
shortly after she loses the will to go
on but she continues to pray Rhea is a
highborn girl who becomes undead she no
longer has a place in her homeland and
is cast away to be forgotten
she does her best but fails to find the
secret of kindling betrayed by a man who
hates her for a high birth tricked by
patches lusted after by law Trek and
responsible for the death of her friends
she is rescued by you the only one in
Lordran who gives her mercy
she repays you with miracles but she
soon teaches you all that she knows and
dissolve no use and there are eyes
watching channelers are the eyes of Seif
and can be found in many lands one of
them frequents the undead church while
their motives are largely uncertain it's
known that Seif captures maidens for his
experiments the channeler spies Rhea as
she prays and takes her to a cell in the
archives and that is where Rhea hollows
and spends the rest of her days if I do
go all oh and finish me off
I beg phew